hello once again Jeremy Corbyn this week
traveled to Geneva to address the UN on
Human Rights and with him was his shadow
Attorney General Baroness Chakrabarti
and she joins me now Shammi as you
prefer to be called out very good
morning to you um
International Human Rights Day today as
you told me in the break thank you are
we doing enough as a nation of influence
I don't think we are the world is facing
the biggest refugee crisis since World
War two and frankly we're not doing
enough on our own doorstep as your very
powerful film from oldham shows we've
got people in this country one of the
wealthiest countries on earth who are
going to be worried about food and
shelter and warmth this this Christmas
that's just completely unacceptable from
a human rights perspective so what do we
do well I think we need to pause and fix
universal credit as a matter of extreme
urgency so that people like Rachel don't
don't freeze or starve or worry about
their kids this Christmas and on the
world stage we've got to put human
rights a part of our foreign policy as
well as our home policy and we've got to
encourage other nations who are our
allies to to follow suit you mentioned
foreign policy then I just want to ask a
couple of questions on we obviously had
the Israeli ambassador to the UK in the
studio a little bit earlier on the
situation as regards Jerusalem I mean it
is pretty troubling but at the same time
why shouldn't as Mark Greg have
suggested why shouldn't Israel have the
same right as any other sovereign state
to choose its capital here's the problem
Jerusalem is of course loved and
cherished by people in Israel by Jewish
people all over the world but it's loved
and cherished by Christians and Muslims
too and for the Palestinians there will
be no Palestinian state without East
Jerusalem so what Donald Trump has done
this week is to is to light the matches
in a tinderbox a wonderful symbolic but
hostile act on his point laughter I was
very surprised that mr. Rieger thought
that this could in any way contribute to
peace as opposed to more problems in
that region and therefore in the world
there are people who have been shot and
killed already and it's only been a few
days
let's turn to brexit because of course
it's been a big week for in brexit
discussions labour is fond of saying
that it likes to keep quite a lot on the
table but I want to try and narrow
things down a little bit now we now know
that labor is in favour of status quo
transition period back in June your
leader 3 front benchers for voting in
favour of skiing in the customs union in
single market this week we had Kia star
Marseille and continued membership of
the customs union in the single market
should be back on the table what what is
your party's policy and our policy has
always been that we want the closest
possible relationship with with our
friends across the channel at the same
time we respect the the referendum
result but it's much easier for us and
it is for the Conservatives because we
are more United about the kind of
country we want to be we respect human
rights as do people elsewhere in Europe
we want workers protections as we
currently get from the EU environmental
protections and so on so so we will have
to deliver these in cooperation with our
European allies yes outside the current
treaty arrangements and in a new treaty
but we're far less divided than the
Conservatives about about what that's
going to do is divided but it does seem
to be because you keep saying things to
appeal to to all people to deramian or
super entities on the issue yeah of
customs union in single market is it the
Labor Party's view that it would be
better to remain in the customs union
single market or no we want something
like that it won't be the customs union
and the single market because those
things are currently deliv delivered as
part of the EU family which we will be
leaving but we want the closest possible
relationship and and of course you know
the Good Friday Agreement was one of the
greatest achievements of the last Labour
government and we would never have
jeopardized that in the way that the
Conservatives have an effort for 18
months of that construction you're using
there the closest possible relationship
with the European Union the people
watching the selamat who voted to leave
the EU who say that's not what I voted
for well I don't think that people voted
to to not be friendly and to not work
closely and not to have a great trade
deal so that we didn't have regulated
regulatory alignment well I mean do they
want environmental protections do they
want workplace protections I think they
do they want human
it's protections I believe they do
certainly we do and that is the case
that we took to people in the general
election that we will keep taking to
them including in the next election all
of which makes the issue of a second
referendum are very interesting when a
John Ashworth told me on this program
that there was no appetite for it Diane
Abbott has been telling her constituents
that she's going to push for one what
what is the party position on them the
party position is that sovereignty was
about parliamentary sovereignty and the
Conservatives have been spurning that
consistently and have been dragged
no you don't I don't I I the carbon has
said that it remains an option but you
haven't made up your minds yet well I
personally don't think that in out
referendums deliver the most
sophisticated or unifying debate I'm you
know maybe others will disagree and that
will happen one day but I think what we
need is a general election and I would
like to see it sooner rather than later
so that we can help people like Rachel
in Oldham and all over this country I'll
bet you'd want to see a general election
sooner rather than later and at that
point you'd have to flesh out exactly
what your position is but you keep
maintaining yeah yours is a government
in waiting
okay freedom of movement Jeremy Corbyn
back in May said it would end when we
come up the EU Rebecca long Bailey key
Astana again both of equivocated on the
topic you said on this Chu in June we
couldn't have complete control of
immigration again there will be no free
movement as currently exists within the
EU treaty because we will be outside it
but there will have to be movement and
people in this country want movement
their kids want to go and study their
kids want to go and work and our NHS
needs nurses and doctors and so there
will be movement and it won't just be
with the EU it will be with people who
want to come and contribute to this
country from all over the world this
week the deliver party's been laying
into the government for for not having
agreed on the end state that they are
the relationship that we will have with
the EU at the end of this process what
is Labour's ideal and state and you
can't use the words that job prospects
it as far as I'm concerned the the ideal
end state will be the closest diplomatic
security and trading relationship with
our nearest neighbors that sounds a lot
like ye lights it but these are
technical terms that you're that you're
using and
politicians and lawyers sometimes used
but I think we need to think about
outcomes that means human rights
protections workplace protections
consumer protections environmental
protections very close cooperation and
not the deregulated offshore tax haven
but too many people in Teresa mayor's
cabinet and party still want us we have
you what do you make of the defense
Secretary's comments this week about
killing Girardi's I was very
disappointed in that let's be clear if
you're on the battlefield then you have
to fight whoever is opposing you on on
the battlefield you seem to be
suggesting that there is a kill list he
seemed to be sedate indeed if he is
suggesting targeted assassinations of
criminals who should instead be brought
to justice as that is appalling and we
do not want to hear a defense secretary
abrogate the rule of law because the
rule of law is what brave men and women
who joined join our armed forces and put
their lives at risk how does that that's
what they do it for for the rule of law
at home and abroad
very very final question it's only a yes
knowing that much has been made this
week of the momentum contract that
document that the campaigning group is
insisting that parliamentary candidates
signed to gain their support would use
the former head of Liberty saying
something like that well I'm not a
parliamentary candidate so nobody's
going to come to me to sign any contract
what to tie my support for Jeremy Corbyn
I don't think I need to sign any piece
of paper to demonstrate that I have
great faith and confidence and shared
values with my leader shall be
Chakrabarty thanks for being with us